díaz señora también por favor las dos
culturas
rocio visita su nieto jerome fallecido a
su mes en el cementerio tradicional
indígena
lo hace cumpliendo con una tradición de
comer sobre su tumba los caracoles
llamados churros
[Música]
este cementerio tradicional indígena de
poder ha mantenido durante 130 años esta
costumbre como un acto de respeto los de
euros como es bebé yo le traje una cola
dita traigo una col arita hace rezar
coladita golosinas como para niños esa
es la tradición igual el comer el churro
el churro ya es una tradición una
costumbre del venir acá porque todo
tradicionalmente o diariamente no se
puede comer solamente cuando se viene al
cementerio se pasa comprando la fondita
de churros para chupar acá en el
cementerio venga venga los churritos
chulos chulos laura es de hendidura de
los churros desde hace 30 años es un
ingreso laboral con el que cuenta cada
día de los muertos como una cultura
heredada
el 2 de noviembre vienen los indígenas
demasiada gente vienen porque son los
indígenas son bien unidos vienen
bastantes familias y como ustedes haya
visto el ingreso principal el ingreso
por las dos vueltas entonces ahí es
donde nosotros nos representa en la
economía para nuestros hogares
esta tradición milenaria no pierde
vigencia y se afianza entre las nuevas
generaciones que cuando uno fallece
el cuerpo en sí el físico se lo entierra
pero el espíritu el alma está vivo
entonces vienes a compartir tal vez con
el espíritu del alma que está ahí laura
también seguirá trabajando en la
temporada no sólo por las ganancias
también porque une a los vivos de
aeropuertos